hello welcome back to big mood
it's a mood in here we do have a very
special guest today
kasim jeeb for those of you who don't
know it's a very og youtuber
very very old very old
used to host quite a few shows
california on was one and then going
deep with casinos that was my favorite
do you remember those days
i do yeah how did it how was it 10 years
ago i don't know 10 years ago i don't
understand
so much better wow i don't get it i
don't get time
i you know it's um i think about
those times as like you know like
there's a lot of cringing i do
you know when you go to bed and then
you're like oh that thing that i did or
i said
yeah and then i'm like oh i got a
private that video in the morning oh no
especially like you know with everything
now
yeah i like to say i canceled myself
because like if i were to do that stuff
now i'd be
you know yeah that'd be like an alex
jones level
somewhere in a bunker but um you know
when you do comedy and you know this
when you start out they always tell you
like do clubs that are not
in l.a yeah outside l.a
do small clubs don't you know
do your bad material yes in front of
people get it out yeah yeah
and then i did all that like online
great
so and then so it's like not only did i
do all that now it's
a video and like you can watch it i i
private a lot but you can watch them
still
and then i'll go and i'll be like oh my
god like who i won't know the person
in the video so do you feel like because
a lot of comedians usually say like oh
well it's comedy i should have a space
to work these things out do you feel
like that or do you feel like oh
actually that was not really appropriate
and i regret it
there's a lot of regret okay you know
but but
also we should have space to like
realize
that we've changed yeah it's like
totally okay and that's kind of like
you know i'm i'm in touch with the
internet so i know the whole jenna
marbles
oh right so it's like i i understand
where she's coming from and
having to remove herself but like we did
a lot of stupid stuff
and we don't we we we
watch it the same way people watch it
now which is like ooh you know yeah yeah
sure you should you know you've grown i
mean years of pass
i was 24 25 i'm i'll be 37 in like two
months so there's like a big
i've learned like my sensibilities
changed a lot and
you're still figuring yourself out
you're figuring your voice out i figured
it out
back then yeah at 24. try to help you
chasm
yeah yeah now i'm ready because i'm sure
i'm trying to mate now
right yeah oh wow let's talk about that
out there i want a kid yeah you want a
kid yeah i and i don't need to be
i'd love to be a single dad ooh did you
hear she's going to go to the egg bank
yeah look at me when you said that maybe
you have a sperm bank for women that
wanted to have you heard there's
actually people
right now that are getting like single
people are getting together just to
create a kid so they're doing
co-parenting
already like yeah they're not even
trying to have a relationship they're
just going in they're like you're
good you have financial stability no
they actually they have websites where
it's kind of like a dating site but
instead of dating you're trying to match
parental approaches so oh that's good
yeah
i would just be like i hope she her nose
isn't big because i i've got
you know i've got enough of that and
then i want her to have good calves and
then i think it would be
small nose nice calves yeah cause i
don't have those things so i want my kid
to grow up with calves
interesting no
very self-conscious okay okay i'd rather
show you my penis
okay yeah is it like the same size yeah
go ahead jess what what do you got
now oh now you're shy those are not yes
circumcised or not
oh god there we go
a couple of days ago in the girl chat
you were texting about how you saw
yourself with my brand
okay don't ruin my brand sorry my
branding
my branding is no children don't [ __ ]
put your [ __ ] inside of me
oh wait you don't want to make babies no
i don't want to come inside you with
birth control and you won't get children
no you don't want cuz you're missing out
on a lot of fun babies i've had plenty
of common me believe me
at this
i don't want kids and nicki's trying to
ruin my brand because i had a soft
moment last week
so i just thought it was sweet and then
it matches like what he's saying because
like
you were like i don't see a man in the
picture but i see a child and it's like
yeah yeah you know she got small nose
nice cats yeah i'm just trying to play
you trying to play imagination you'll
know that you get a heat there's like
heat that builds
get out of here yeah it'd be great to
have a little guy running around
what about a girl no no well see that
doesn't match my
it was a girl in mind i actually do
think and my mom
told me this she's like yeah your first
one she's going to be
a girl i just know that's what my mom i
have three
crazy yeah yeah what's up with mom's
girls
my cousin has two girls my uncle has
three girls
um our yeah our lineage i think is
looking like it's gonna end a lot of
women
i guess you better get on that
yeah perfect yeah how do you say your
last name i mean i've been saying in
gariba but
oh that's not what i said no that was
close
or something i'm like oh he's i just i
just yeah like a garibaldi fish and then
i'm like that's something
it's something yeah we're like the
chocolate company
and the bean company the goya
ghirardelli yeah so
well okay just mix them just put them
together
chocolate beans chocolate beans so
um no i'd love you know i'd love to
scope out your uterus
you want to scope it i need to see how
if you're
the walls of your uterus can are thick
enough for an egg
ah one egg just i can't test that
i have a number of different methods
okay yeah yeah
what's the first method well i get in
there i get
first of all get
you know where the q-tip is moist
nice just just one part of the q-tip
will be moisturizing
okay and then you test it in the petri
dish or something yeah you got some
good testing i didn't know the podcast
was going to be like this what did you
either do
no i just thought like you guys were um
you were going to talk about likes
software i thought we were stopping for
the set right right yeah
i'm really sorry we are soft though we
can be soft would you like would you
like a soft touch
no we're all just so horny i was like
no with the children my vagina dropped
i've been trying to have kids so this
ovulation week this week oh okay so
we're trying to bang all the jobs
it's not fun it's not fun
well because there's a pressure it's
like well you know like at first it's
like
oh yeah like it's ovulation week
why is there pressure there literally
doesn't have to be because we're tired
because you just wanted to happen you're
tired
no no we're tired because of life so
like the pandemic
in the way the idea of having children
fires you out no no no
the idea of trying to sext tires me out
like at the end of the day like you
you're like okay we're going to do
it today beginning of the day we can't
because he has a process in the morning
i try to good morning you guys are too
old for this
just just let it go what just let it go
you can't have sex in the morning i want
sex in the morning that's my time to
shine your husband is
your husband he's too old for this he
needs to brush his teeth take a shower
wash his balls and then by that time
it's like two hours i'm like i'm
out of the mood like i gotta get my [ __ ]
started like the day's gonna
also wake up earlier than he does i wake
up way earlier so he
refuses to put a dirty dick inside of
you well i and yeah and i've gotten
used to a clean dick and so i don't
think at this point i can go back before
i was used to dirty dicks i was like
this is different having a clean the
morning dick in the morning vagina
it's like it smells like flowers down
there every time and i cannot we cannot
go back
i can't go back do you wash your dick
chasm well you know
keep wet wipes handy okay well that's
that's chemically
yeah no like if you got some organic
ones what gina has a question
my question is in the shower do you
spread your butt cheeks of the water and
soak those
yeah in the shower like a little bend
over
arch my back move it's hot hot
yeah i think i'm in like a late night
cinemax yeah
my ex did that a lot i saw a lot of bent
back
i have two shower puffies and one's for
uh
the butt hole and then one's for the
rest of the box what if you mix them up
they don't know they're different colors
okay i got a whole box i order them on
amazon so i i
get new ones every like i want to say
every week but it's every month i'm
doing something wrong because i don't
have two different loops me neither
neither do i ever what you're doing is
you're taking your poop and you're
putting none of those first
and you know white people don't clean
their legs so i don't go that far i
cleaned my legs you don't clean your
legs kidding
got dirty it's a joke white people don't
clean their legs
my ex wouldn't wash anything past where
her
sheep she wouldn't benefit this is one
of the many reasons why i'm single
there's no arch back with her there's no
she was the man this is where her arm
ended
this was all unwashed and she just
assumed the water would
handle it filthy shins yeah
that's why i mean no calves right that's
why she wouldn't wash them
yeah it made her calves look bigger the
way the dirt built
up that's contouring yeah i added a
shadow
nice uh yeah i guess i just uh i just
figure the soap handles everything so
i'm like i don't know i'll put it
everywhere
we don't need this without even rubbing
my whole thing is the towel like i don't
want like if i clean out my [ __ ] i'm
not gonna put it on my face again you
know so
two towels or one just one towel i heard
a girl's doing two now
two towels that's successful one for the
hair
okay and then one for the body you don't
do the um
okay so so i dry off and then i put the
one in my hair and then i put a bathrobe
on ah
that's the way to do it i guess i'm
disgusting because i don't do any of
that well you're single see that's what
happens
i wipe my ass i wipe my face with the
same towel oh my god
all in one moment the pink eye i've
never gotten pink eye
okay well that's good i'm like you know
the conkers with all the
germs like it doesn't affect me right
right right
cool colonizers yeah colonizers gotcha
yeah
i feel like uh those are the jeans i
want yeah
i feel
see you know guys get together i want to
dilute the brown
dilute it yeah just so they have like a
chance
you know mixed babies are really cute
yeah you gotta have it you gotta have
some
airy i don't know but i have i have
redhead jeans i have redhead jeans so
you might have a soulless child
oh wow oh you know what they say about
gingers i feel like we would have a soul
this child oops
good okay yeah awesome yeah
between you two yeah you definitely have
a soulless child
don't be really funny though true good
it'll be good if you have a good
with dark humor yeah good dry sort of
like
yeah you know just won't smile yeah
ever and you're like is that kid joking
or i can't tell if it's [ __ ] with me
his name is damian yes happy birthday
are you happy
don't send me to the cornfield yes jesus
all right yeah so well good luck you
know i hope uh i hope something
attaches me too if not i'm blaming
steve's [ __ ] i keep blaming it
i'm like i'm horny i'm ready yeah has he
gotten it look at that energy drinks
he's gotten a sperm check no but i was
like after this cove
[ __ ] is over we're getting your
fertility checked because
they have at-home tests oh do they yeah
oh yeah just mail that [ __ ]
yeah he drinks way too much monster way
too many energy drinks oh yeah way too
much a lot in there
i know mine work because i had an
abortion oh [ __ ] you had an abortion
yourself well you know i would i was
impregnated one half of the
gotcha you know of the the murder
contributing force just kidding i'm
kidding
yeah no i'm pro i'm probably abortion
i'm pro-abortion
it's not a life yet i was young
i just couldn't i'm trying to back out
of this because i had like a kid already
jesus
i was drinking yeah i didn't want to be
a dad oh
uh no it was just it was one of those
complete accidents
and neither of us were like right so
moving on
well they do say if you want to get
pregnant you should drink i have been
relaxes you i have i've been drinking
before
because i'm i'm ready and i'm stressed
like i take all the stress out
and then i drink after because i'm
pissed that i didn't get pregnant
oh so i'm drinking all the time i don't
know what's happening i don't know
what's wrong with me
yeah no i'm sure it's steve yeah
i mean i mean looking at him it's
probably steve's
probably listen to the combination of
the energy drinks
yeah i went to my gynecologist and sorry
kasim i know you're talking about
your own system no i love the video my
gynecologist had a different system
she stuck a um what's it called an
ultrasound up there
and she was showing me my ovaries and
she's like you're very
fertile yeah she was like you're how do
they tell
because okay so that little eggs they
were like
jazzed up like they were at a [ __ ]
club
and she's like you see how energetic
they are there's this little mechanism
attached to the ovaries when you're at a
certain level and they're like why
haven't you made a baby yet and it just
like [ __ ]
jazzes them up all day like get ready to
make babies and they're like we're ready
and then they go down the ovaries every
month and they're just so [ __ ] jazzed
to make a baby yeah
and then yes and then i have my period
and they're like
oh yeah it's sad and i'm i'm
i feel guilty that i let them down you
know yeah
well look you guys will get there you
know and that baby you know
it's unfortunate laughter can't make
babies on
on its own we tried that yeah you can't
laugh a baby into existence
you got to have uh a [ __ ] that's what
they're called
a [ __ ] yeah that's a technical term um
i i think uh
i don't want to ask how old you are how
do you how old i think i am
oh i've known you since you were a very
young buck since you were a minor yeah
yeah so
that was 10 years ago yeah i'm like in
my 20s still
um then you you do you you've always had
the same face
thank you yeah your attitude has just
gotten worse
right right yeah i i think it was always
there it just came out more
right now yeah yeah yeah i remember you
were dating this
guy that we nev i never met but you
dated him forever yeah
yeah i did five years you were actually
dating a girl forever at that time i was
her name was the same name same name
wait what is he
yeah he was dating a girl named can you
[ __ ] believe that
just kidding
no we were both in long-term
relationships when we met and yeah i did
think i was going to marry that guy
because
it was my first very long relationship
did you think you were going to marry
that girl yeah
for a for a period yeah yeah because
it's like wow we've been doing this for
a while it's comfortable i get it
like this is the next step yeah it's the
next thing and then i was like
why am i not why am i not happy like i'm
not like yeah
i can't picture myself like being happy
and friends forever
i also lost my sex drive completely like
i i was like maybe it's just because i'm
career oriented like i don't have a sex
drive
anymore and then i started like checking
out other like other guys would like
turn me on
just by being just by existing and i'm
like nope i still have a sex drive
yep it's this guy and so i had to break
up with him but it was
really hard because yeah there wasn't a
thing it was just like
yeah that was my same deal yeah yeah and
like she just had it her first kid
and it's like oh you know that's like
i'm so happy she got
oh recently yeah yeah and it's like uh
she
i always knew she was gonna be a great
mom you know what i mean
but when you're i was with her from 20
to 25
and you just become every year like a
completely different
person yeah my frontal lobe like
hardened
yes you know like when i was 21 22 and
then
you just start to see thing i mean you
just kind of grow
yeah that's what happened but she was
great and she's still a great person
yeah totally to keep in touch with your
exes
what's the question yeah well i
yeah as much as you can like i'm on good
terms with
almost i'd say i'm on good terms with
all of them
and then we'll text maybe half of them
ever like on a birthday
oh yeah yeah do you think it's uh weird
like when you're dating a new person
like
if you were to contact your exes during
that time or do you kind of like
do you kind of not text your ex's after
when i'm
dating a new person i think my attention
is just on the
new person and then yeah i don't want to
like make it make the other
new girl feel weird like right right
yeah because that sucks
yeah cause then i wonder too because i'm
not the type to
really talk to my exes at all just
because
he's the father of my child but other
than that i wouldn't i don't talk to any
of my other exes
so i always wonder people that do
maintain a relationship like how do they
honor the the relationship that they're
in but also honor
the friendship that they have with their
exes yeah
i'm like how does that work and that
friendship by the way takes
a while to happen like at least a year
or two after you've separated yeah and
it's a clean break it can't be any of
that like we'll hook up every
few months yeah no benefits involved
right it's got to be but i i think not
talking to them is
just as healthy you know i i totally i
totally get that i
i'd never it's i've never like been
never had it end super badly to where
like oh i can't ever talk to that
right right and then when you get sober
you do amends and things like that which
also like helps you clean up your side
of things oh yeah
you want to be able to walk down the
street and see
uh one of these people and not have to
worry about like oh [ __ ] i should cross
the street right now like
true you know you just want to live that
kind of life i wish i
had a stylist picking out my clothes
every day like a princess
and now i can't with stitch fix because
stitch fix is a company that you go
online
you fill out a profile um they'd send
you like little pictures of clothes and
you say
yes or no to them you say yay or nay
like a princess would
and then they hook you up with a stylist
who picks out your wardrobe for you
sends you a box full of clothes you get
to try them on you get to
you know check yourself out in the
mirror see if you dig it see if
see if it's it holds up to your
standards and if you like everything you
keep it
and if you don't like it you send it
back no questions asked
you pay a 20 styling fee for each fix
which is credited towards anything you
keep
so it's really not like you're paying
for that styling fee which is crazy
because stylists are so expensive
you can schedule at any time there's no
subscription required plus
shipping returns and exchanges are easy
and free stitch fix does all the hard
work for you making great style
effortless for everybody including women
men and kids
get started today at stitchfix.com
no not nude nope oh do not go there the
opposite
put clothes on that body ma'am oh no get
started today at stitchfix.com
mood and you'll get 25 off
when you keep everything in your fix
that's stitchfix.com
mood for 25 off when you keep everything
in your fix
stitchfix.com mood and when you're
looking good you want to smell good too
you don't
want to be all sweaty and sticky and
gross and that's where
native comes in so native
doesn't just block odor better it's made
better native has ingredients that
you've actually heard of like coconut
oil shea butter
uh tapioca starch it's also vegan and
it's
never tested on animals did you guys
know that
are right like you know the regular
disgusting
thing don't say it it has aluminum plugs
yeah it forms a plug in your sweat
glands with the aluminum plug
it has like your tumeric coming out i'm
saying the words stop saying that word
it's nasty man you don't want you do not
want to plug
up your sweat glands to keep you from
sweating that's not natural that's
that's gross
so that's why native never uses
ingredients like aluminum parabens
sulfates or talc
and so dude i am in love with it so i
brought my
my own native right here i like to say
how the paper
packaging exactly so now cardboard right
now they have a plastic free cap
what plastic free packaging and this is
my personal favorite the cucumber and
mint
it is amazing i keep it in my car it's
it always comes through
it blocks odors it keeps me nice and dry
so do what i did and make the switch to
native today by going to native
deo.com big mood girls or use promo code
big mood girls at checkout and get 20
off your first order that's
native d-e-o dot com slash
big mood girls or use promo code big
mood girls at checkout for 20
off your first order and i love natives
i love using our codes when i
know i use all of our code everything i
feel like a drug dealer dipping into my
own stash
they don't know it's me
so we talked about kids and stuff and
then we were kind of talking about
long-term relationships do you do you
see yourself getting married
yeah well i only see it because i think
i have to do that to have the kids
mm-hmm
but if there was a a woman that didn't
need to get married to
create a family with you you'd be down
for that yeah i don't i don't feel like
marriage um i think it's changing
a little bit and it's really just
like i think there's some tax incentives
but others you know um i don't i could
or i couldn't it wouldn't really make a
difference if
if my partner was like well i have to
kind of be a wife to have a kid i'll be
like okay
okay yeah let's see how exciting that's
romantic
yeah yeah would you be open to the thing
that i mentioned earlier where you just
meet someone
solely for the purpose of creating a
child together
not necessarily having a romantic you
need love in your relationship i think
well i think that depends on how
desperate and old i get you know i think
right now i still got some juice
yeah to where i could romance
plenty of time but yeah we do have more
time
which is great which is awesome i'm only
getting better
honestly i think men do get better
looking as they get older yeah i was
just
super you know you were all nerdy before
and now i'm
not now look at you yeah sex icon i
actually i really like
i like how men age yeah yeah it's uh
not all men you know sure not all men my
dad
horribly yeah um but yeah i i guess it
would just be
a depends on how you still have you
still have a little
a little juice left to romance somebody
yeah oh it's in there
and it's you know it's like like your
ovaries are having a par a party yeah
there's a version of that you got like
it's in my heart
yeah yeah they they do a little
chocolate beans
chocolate beans those like the mexican
jumping beans inside of your nutsack
what a mystery those were yeah well uh
earlier before
no idea before the podcast started um
you know we were talking about marriage
and like how like you were invited to my
wedding
and like yeah like you didn't show up to
my wedding and none of these people were
invited
and they get reached out all the time
yeah they're always like we didn't get
invited to your wedding
and i'm like yeah i mean we invited some
friends and it's something that's the
first i'm hearing of it
it's always fun to believe that yeah uh
look it is possible that um
it i just didn't care no no i i
you guys you and steve have always been
people have i've liked and i would have
definitely gone i
don't i don't have an excuse of why i
don't remember getting an invitation
but it doesn't mean i didn't get one i
was drinking a lot
a lot that was right when i got sober
probably found it when you were drunk
you're like [ __ ]
yeah probably you like use it to light
up liners
you know there was there was a lot of
there was a lot going on at that time so
i want to formally apologize
to you and steve and i'm trying to i
want to make it up i've been talking
with steve
yeah every few months i love that via
twitter dms yes
and then um we're gonna hang gonna have
a barbecue yeah you can come
thank you i have been every night
but no baby has happened yeah yeah well
yeah
you know you'll i i guess you should
announce it
because it's a big deal or the baby no
the baby like the second it happened
right yeah well i guess you can't
because there's two months where
you can lose it true i'm i'm still going
to claim it
you do it and be like my maid you know i
made the start of something yeah
and then celebrate the miscarriage if it
happens yeah there's a way to
it's an honor just to be inseminated yes
that's perfect i love it um you're
choking on salami yeah
such a mild level of choking for gina
she likes it
a lot worse than that you guys are great
are there any turn-offs
in uh you know what that felt like just
now it felt like the dating
the dating game the dating show game
where it's like
so uh number three like on mtv yeah yeah
yeah no like the 1960s like
i'm picking like mtv like jenny they
tried to recreate those shows for sure
yeah yeah um but yeah
for sure for sure yeah you have to you
can't be an anti-vaxxer
right oh is that is she that's what
she's known for
oh i feel like she spearheaded that i
totally [ __ ] missed that
was it when she was dating jim carrey
yeah um
is he an anti-vaxxer i don't know that
would be extremely unfortunate i don't i
wouldn't have like the 45 minutes to
wait around if you asked him like
it would take a while he has gone off
into like conspiracy land so
um i wouldn't put it interesting but
anyway so no antibacters um
we're trying to hook you up you know so
we're trying to oh i appreciate that
romance out there there's a lot of women
watching yeah
i know i know if you've heard all this
stuff about miscarriages and abortions
you're probably like that's the man
for me do you date people that
have seen you online like are you open
to the no i
generally will well one person
uh but we had mutual friends but i've
never
met somebody it's always somebody that's
been a friend of a friend or i've been
introduced through a friend yeah and
that's like
i gotta say that's the best way to meet
a girl
is if like you were to vet me to one of
your friends and be like oh here's cass
you know he's like
mostly not a creep and you can go on a
date with him and then they're like oh
nikki thinks he's okay and then you know
yeah there's that when you
when you meet there's that sort of like
a window yeah like this person thought
we were both okay
to be in this place together so you like
getting so uh
jess i have this friend it's nice it's
so awkward
he's a little older he's his frontal
cord
do you know how old we are stop trying
to act 22 nikki listen
i'm very young okay okay always young at
heart yeah okay that's how you stay yeah
see so yeah i think but you know i i
heard you guys talking about dating apps
earlier i think you mentioned something
about hinge yeah i'm not on any right
now
i don't know if i could handle that i
don't know if i can handle making a
profile
that's pretty terrible somebody you know
judging me based on like five
pictures or uh so you've never tried
i've never done a dating app you're not
missing much to be honest
well you know my ex's sister was like
that was her
her whole day revolved around her
conversations
i don't know if i yeah i've never dated
somebody that i didn't
i wasn't friends with first it's always
been like we hang out in a group and
we're friends and i know them for a
while
and i mean like steve like i knew him
for three years before
we started dating i don't know enough
like guy like i don't
i don't interact with enough men in real
life i think that's the reason why i was
willing to say the person you get
married to
you've already met them by age 26. what
well i am sure i don't know if that's
true but i was like this is [ __ ]
because at 26 i was single and i was
like
looking at my facebook friends list i
was like i think i was silly i was still
in
texas at 26.
maybe they'll move out here i don't know
i don't know everyone's moving to texas
that's true i left texas i'm not going
back i heard it's very humid
it's humid there's a hell of mosquitoes
not for me it's
there's a lot of racists all right it's
just not for me i like the tax breaks
but i feel like you could get them in
vegas
so we're looking at yeah you don't have
to jump all the way to town are you
really we are
i've been you know so funny that
everyone's talking about it because i've
i've never thought out
live anywhere besides california just in
the last two weeks it's been like
what you thought about austin same like
i really i was born and raised here
santa barbara honestly for me if i would
move anywhere i'd want to go somewhere
internationally really yeah me too
i want to learn a different language
europe or something because i did spend
one year
living in mexico so that was like cool i
thought you were born and raised in
mexico
one year when i was 15. 2005.
okay back to the back to you what were
we talking about
moving yeah yeah moving yeah the first
time i've ever thought it would
i could probably live somewhere else
yeah and this these last two weeks
has been the first time you ever
considered it yeah because that like now
that the guys i do my podcast with
they're like everyone's talking about it
you know joe rogan
yeah a lot of comedians and a massive
amount of people move it like like you
can bring your friend group with you
it's worth it but
not as a one person right not worth it i
think that's what the thing is right now
is that a lot of people want to move
i think because i mean the pandemic
forced everybody we're all inside anyway
you're not even enjoying the benefits of
what you're paying for like you're
paying i mean i honestly enjoyed driving
my car in la and seeing the palm trees
in the mountains and everything i would
never give that up to go live in texas
that's cute it's cute here i love it
here
i love it here too i don't want to give
it up but
i love california and like the you know
the weather's great and there's a lot to
see it's just
like uh i don't know how we fix
the homelessness i don't know how you
know there's obviously a housing crisis
i mean there's
so many things that were like kind of
like we kind of
stepped over 10 years ago yeah i'm just
like
oh there's a guy sleeping on the
sidewalk yeah it's like i'll get a
coffee over here but like now
that the encampments and everything are
just like they're their own zip codes
and it's just
it's a completely different i mean i
don't know if you've been to skid row
downtown
yeah it's like another place i used to
live in little tokyo so
i've seen it yeah so i don't i don't
know i mean there's a lot and then you
see the governor and i'm a
i'm a liberal democrat but when you see
like gavin newsom
come up and speak and it's like just a
lot of platitudes and a lot of like
you know we just just like sayings that
are
kind of empty yeah there's nothing
happening so i don't know
um all right so we're looking for people
in texas
good shin small nose yeah good calves
good kids yeah your shins i'm really
whatever was [ __ ]
you know you know what they say about
calves it takes every behind every good
cab is good [ __ ]
oh that's yeah yeah yeah yeah they
always say that
because you know cavs have always gotten
the spotlight yeah
and those shades you need a bone to hold
onto you know so it's like oh look this
[ __ ] perfectly good shin right
perfectly good [ __ ] do you believe in
destiny because maybe you're heading
towards your future wife ooh i you know
i do
like to uh a spiritual i'm spiritual
and then by and i when i say that i i
listen to like uh
like meditation podcasts oh do you like
eckhart tolle
and yeah although that book was so
boring which one
the power announcement yeah the power of
now try the other one i listen to it on
audio
better audio it's amazing
it's really
but like i'm trying to focus i can't if
i'm falling asleep
i don't know that's the thing because
it's like way too
like this he takes a lot of pauses
that's the point
and then like this i'd rather have the
headspace guy do it
he's too australian for me i like it i
always find myself questioning like why
did he say that word like that or like
why did he pause
yeah i'm like is this psychological is
he like getting into my head do i
understand it more because he's like
he's always saying everyone i think he's
gonna zap yeah yeah he's unpredictable
like that's
completely unpredictable do you ever
watch love island
the british yeah the british women have
like captions on
i can't understand what they're saying
half the time without the captions well
on your
second or third season of it oh i'm on
like season five
you've gotta yeah you just still haven't
caught on to the accent
uh no i i we talk in that accident all
the time we were like hey bro
what you doing rob yeah come here uh we
get on like a house on fire mate
and like that's that's our warm-up
getting into bed
maybe that's why you're not having kids
because honestly kids are not attractive
that's true they don't have kids on that
show yeah um
yeah yeah i it is a i we i do like my
reality
shows um love island top reality shows
one of five go do you like i'm a
bachelor guy
oh yeah you know and i think in the last
few years bachelor's kind of had this
resurgence although i don't think it's
the best i just enjoy the um
the off season like the uh internet
yeah around it yeah like following them
on ig
i have a whole account on instagram that
just you have a vinsta it's a
is that a fake yes yeah i have one
that's
just for bachelors wow
i'm a little bit excited about that i
just only follow bachelors i don't know
if you should tell people this
i think he's lying uh no no i do because
i was gonna do a bachelor
segment on the podcast which i didn't
and um but i want
for a while and i was hosting these
weekly sort of watch parties
and i had to know i had to know what was
going on off camera
do you know that the the last bachelor
he's with kelly now
he's with that lawyer kelly that got she
didn't even make it top five
oh oh yes yeah yeah yeah pete yeah pete
and kelly are together now um yeah i did
know that
and uh gossip for you guys out there i
don't know anything i dm'd
one time did you i forget what but he
responded back and now he's my favorite
he's because he responded yeah he just
needs some attention don't you
i'll die i'll die just a little bit of
attention give this man please
he's from west lake which is like where
i kind of grew up oh that's cool the
poorer part like
newbury park so where's that like
thousand oaks area
yes kind of far it's the next town i
didn't know you were in the 805
area yeah i'm an 805 barbara 805
what what yeah everyone like once we got
our own beer
yeah everyone was like what's this zip
code all about true yeah yeah
yeah steve had no idea then he that was
like all the 805's you got to try them
like the stuff
that was from miami nope which was
miami's i don't know is always saying it
i i have no idea all i know is dale
who knows um so have you found that it's
harder to date after
having like youtube success like being a
public figure is it
has it changed like the dating scene for
you uh
hmm well you know it's so
i i would consider like my actual dating
life like had probably just
started right when that started oh yeah
i was in a long-term relationship
you know kind of before youtube took off
and then after
you know if anything you know
uh it might have made it like more
interesting because you get more
messages in your inbox but like
uh it it hasn't translated to an
actual relationship yeah nothing like
worthwhile or anything like that but um
you know do what do you look for when
you're
when you're dating i guess now like what
other than besides the cavs yeah i need
a sense of humor
but like uh you know one that
works with my sense of humor you know
she's gotta be cool joking about
abortion she's gotta be into big bang
theory and abortion
uh yeah no it's it's uh
i i i look i look for looks
i look for looks yeah i love an honest
man
and then like see you know i can't you
can't be too hot
you can't be you know like you guys are
describing me
like you don't have to sub tweet me
she's looking at you and it's great
likes dark humor is is hot but not too
hot
his name starts with a j he's gotta have
some insecurities anyhow so if you guys
need someone to talk to especially
during these times it's very weird uh
change is constant but in the new normal
now that is covid it feels like there's
something new to grapple with every day
you can now get 24 7 access to the
support you need with talkspace
talkspace is basically like a
online therapy app that you can talk to
a real licensed therapist
uh you can text them you can voice
message them you can even facetime them
and they check your message or they
check the messages multiple times a day
five days a week and they respond to you
so right now you can't really go to a
therapist office and sit there and talk
you can do it now
over your phone whenever you want to 24
7 which i love because
i don't want to have to wait a whole
week about like
and remember all my feelings and
thoughts whatever and speak to them once
a week
now when i'm really going crazy i can
message them
and tell them everything that i'm
feeling in the moment and then they'll
come back and they'll talk to me
it's extremely affordable talkspace is a
fraction of the cost of
in-person therapy and now talkspace
covers
40 million people for online therapy
through their insurance or employer
cool right yeah i gotta check it out
cause i've been thinking about
hitting up um a therapist again because
i haven't been
in a minute yeah yeah that insurance
thing is a real big
plus yeah and it's really cool so you go
on their app and then you
kind of answer these questions like what
do you want to work on what kind of
therapy
do you want to get and then they'll
match you with like a bunch and then you
take
or you're picking who you want to talk
to you can vibe them out for a little
bit if you don't like you can always
switch to someone else um
the network is composed of thousands of
licensed therapists
and it even shows you what kind of
licenses they have and credentials they
have
and their experience in treating
depression anxiety substance abuse
trauma relationship issues food and
eating and so much more it's completely
secure
and private and during these times we
all need someone to talk to
talkspace wants to give us the support
we deserve at a price we can afford
match with your perfect therapist at
talkspace.com or by downloading the
talkspace app
and don't forget to use the promo code
mood
at checkout for a hundred dollars off
your first month
that's a hundred doll hairs off your
first month at talkspace.com
that's a promo code dollars
yeah like the episode just doesn't feel
complete unless you say it yeah
it's a lot of doll hairs well it is now
time for me to give the hellofresh ad
that i've been waiting for
get it girl food is therapy for me too
it's really nice to be seeing you
cooking i've been cooking a lot more
myself
in between i do like to order some
hellofresh and and
learn new recipes from them that's the
that's my favorite part about hellofresh
is like the recipes that i get to learn
with the box that they bring the things
that i get to pick out
each week also it cuts out the meal
planning and grocery store trips
some weeks i just don't feel like
thinking about what i want to cook and i
just want to go on there pick a few
things and then they'll send it to me
makes it so much faster so much easier
over 90 of the ingredients are sourced
directly from the growers to ensure the
freshest recipes
are being delivered to your door and you
can easily change your delivery days or
food preferences and skip a week
whenever you need
so to try out america's number one meal
kit go to hellofresh.com
slash 80 big mood which is the number
eight zero
and use code 80 big mood to get a total
of eighty dollars off
your first month which is a lot
including free shipping on your first
box
a lot of what a lot of doll hairs
additional restrictions apply
uh but go to hellofresh.com for more
details and then go to hellofresh.com
80 big mood and use the code 80 big mood
to get a total of
eighty dollars off your first month
including free shipping on your first
box additional restrictions apply please
visit hellofresh.com for details
that's so many doll heads we just saved
you guys like so much money
back to dating you said you look for
looks like what is there anything
specific that
you're like oh like do you have a type
uh
you know what i i've been not having
i used to think like oh i like redheads
i like pale redheads and i've said that
but like
it's really coming out of my last
relationship
i think the a big thing i look for now
is like how compatible our
lifestyle is yeah because that was a big
you know sticking point you know she
woke up early
um didn't like to stay home i like
woke up at a regular time uh what's a
regular time like eight
you know like eight or nine she woke up
earlier than that yeah yeah geez
she has this well it's a whole thing and
it's like
how much time yeah like eight is early
yeah she got up real early and then she
was like a workaholic and she's very
successful and has her own business and
blah blah blah
and um made a ton of money and it was
cool
but um would really expect
me to kind of wait also wake up early
and like connect in the mornings and
like it's very tough for me to
wake up really early yeah going through
the same struggles right now in my
marriage
like casey wishes that the warning
person super not morning person
dude i don't know what's wrong with
these people i'm a morning person i love
that
steve sleeps in because i get that those
hours to myself exactly
i get to meditate i get to do my
journaling
creative [ __ ] and then he wakes up and
i'm all like ready to go
yeah i think that's that's great yeah
it just differs from person to person
right so lifestyle's huge
yep lifestyle is totally huge it has to
be compatible and
you know i don't think she really
she was so busy and like running her own
business and then like the fact that i
just like kind of did a podcast and like
you know you weren't doing enough yeah
not enough um
you know even though i own my own home
and like does she know who you
are okay yeah it's like did you even
watch my videos do you know you kind of
did that already like you you
i know and that was kind of like you
know in therapy there was a lot of like
well you know he's on another
another chapter of his life he's like
trying to you know figure out
i i i'm in a very fortunate position
where i i
can take time to like really figure out
how i want to move in the next
few years and um she wanted it kind of
like
quicker and there was like a sort of
like a lack of respect thing there
and it was just it was a bunch of stuff
like that because i could relate if you
were just some bomb that like wasn't
doing anything like you
you didn't have a job and you didn't
have money and she was providing for you
or something that but i feel like you
i never yeah i always paid for my i mean
there was there's never a situation
where
i was like hey can i buy i lent her
money so we could buy a house
so it was like yeah there's a lot of
like well you're you're kind of on me
about this but like i just like you
should be a certain level of respect
for those of you who don't know kasim g
was one of the founders of maker studios
which was like what started the whole
mcn
multi-channel network and we ruined it
that's true
it got bought by disney and it was a
very big splash huge
no one had any idea what they were doing
that was never a goal of ours and it was
just like
cool but there's a whole new generation
that doesn't even know about any of that
that watches youtube and they don't
they're like what's maker and i'm like
wow
you guys don't even yeah i'll get a
message every once in a while like you
ruined
you ruined what what the internet was
i'm like dude
i just i don't know what to tell you
like i went to google
everybody was bumbling through the
internet you know was in a suit
and like making all these decisions and
like no yes
through in this part of the internet
yeah yeah uh it's just very fortunate
no more yeah it was one of those things
so it um
but yeah logan paul is my fault right
yeah
you have to take the blame of it all
yeah yeah both pauls
but you guys put in a lot of hours you
were we did i mean you were part of that
yeah yeah i mean my manager ruined that
part for me like i can't
oh yeah that guy was a you know am i not
allowed to say
no i'm not allowed to say you could say
whatever you want i didn't remember him
being a great dude
he yeah just leave a comment yeah um so
kasim and i almost had a show
where we were going to talk about sex
and stuff yeah but my manager was like
well you're going out for disney
nickelodeon it's going to ruin
everything
and now look at where you are and now
almost all i do is talk about sex yeah
it would have been great
would have been awesome maybe not
wouldn't have had going deep with custom
g so that's oh that was before going
it was before that was my favorite thing
you did we were oh thanks yeah yeah and
those are one of the things where i look
back now i'm like dude who's that
you can't cringe at that there's a lot
even now because i was like does it hold
up because i was like doing some
research on like what's this pajama
pants thing about and like
yeah why is it called that there's no
people
wasn't my pajamas or pants involved um
yeah and i was i was kind of like
looking through your old stuff and i was
like i remember like when you used to do
going deep and like it was
like it was so funny and and sometimes
things don't hold up
i watched a few episodes and it holds up
oh well thank you you're very funny
oh well thank you congrats we had a lot
of things don't get a big head
too late yeah it's just one of those
things you could never do
now you know right and i've tried to i i
even sent logan paul because he
he he like you guys are buds
he had what is your fault he does this
podcast and he brings a uh
he brought a porn star on yeah and he um
would title the podcast going deep with
oh
which is the same exactly and i don't
know trying to put your dick down
so when that yeah so when that happened
i was getting a bunch of tweets like hey
this guy's
ripping you off i'm like well i looked
at it he's like not doing the format
he's just doing a podcast with a pointer
he just took the name yeah
and so i was like having fun with him on
twitter and like i pretended to be his
manager and i had this email
like please send me all of the business
you want to engage with logan
and um and so he ended up following me
it was kind of like fun banter back and
forth
well just really for me to him
and there was like i was like i would do
i would do a new one
if i could do him you know and like i
was like oh i think there's a way to do
this now and i would start with him
yeah and i sent him a message like hey
dude would you ever like you know think
it'd be pretty funny and
no he was like nah who are you yeah
who's this old guy in my dms
uh so there was uh so i think there is a
version of it that works now but
um i think i like having that stuff just
be there
and then we'll just gonna do different
things yeah it makes sense i mean you
know steve's channel
got completely demonetized he used to do
um oh yeah
yeah he used to do the bang bus things
with porn stars
and and the joke was that uh he would
find people on the street
and ask them if they wanted to being a
porn star and then he'd get them in the
van
they sign a waiver and then yeah the
porn stars would pick up the cameras and
they were like the crew
and two male guys would come in like
okay let's get this [ __ ] on
and uh youtube was like this is not
satire this is real sex
this is real this is a real porn
happening he had a i had one
making fun of sam pepper where it was
like sex in public and he had like
blurred out
like he would just go up to random
people and be like won't have sex and
like they'd be like yeah and they just
[ __ ] in the street
and then like the cop comes over he's
like hey what are you doing and they're
like want to have sex and then the cop
has sex with them too
like it's clearly a sketch yeah and
youtube is like no this is how do people
like what's that other guy's name
brandon
um [ __ ] i mean you guys in the comments
know who it is but he's an extremely
graphic youtuber with his sketches like
extremely graphic and he's got he gets
millions of views and i'm like how is
this guy surviving i don't see a bunch
of sponsors or anything
i'm like he's is he not does he have
that maybe he's just trying to get
audience and then leverage it
yeah i don't know maybe he gets money
some other way but this is all because
kasim ruined youtube so
let's not forget that you can email me
yeah
yeah there was you know there's there's
so many things i think
and i remember getting demonetized and
and looking at all
because i was making like some money
yeah on youtube
um from just people uh reminiscing and
going through old videos and then one
day it all went away
so the whole idea was that you build
enough of a video library and then
you're making passive income and you
don't really have to think about it
anymore
yeah but uh then youtube just
cherry-picked who
they get to demonetize and it's kind of
crazy that a lot of you they're like
you guys made money off of maker
you're gonna get demons honestly like
because you know how large the jk
library is too yeah a lot of the stuff
from like like pre like like few years
ago
is just all getting demonetized now but
our current stuff isn't so i wonder if
there's like
a thing where they don't want you to
have that much money coming in like
passively
somehow they're putting a cap yeah like
kind of like well you can monetize the
new stuff but not the old stuff like
they're just
cutting so much of the old [ __ ] for some
reason it's crazy
i don't know conspiracy well you know
they're they're the people there that
work at youtube
have just like i think there's like two
guys
you know and they're like the you know
they're in charge of all like these
content creators i remember somebody
telling me that
96 of youtube's ad revenue just comes
from people going into the youtube
search bar
and like googling or youtubing something
versus the other four percent
or less than were people seeking out
their create like the people
the creators or something like that so
type of youtuber user that i
am i don't yeah actually yeah so why why
put
you know assets and resources on that
like four percent
you know and like have people that
actually like are looking out for
creators i think they tried to do a
version of that at one point it just
didn't
it doesn't seem i just think there's two
guys there that are like this person
says that they got a copyright strike
but like or whatever like demonetized
and like
you know there's there's no real reason
yeah they don't care and then because of
that they've
like sites like twitch got big because
youtube just didn't get behind live
programming early enough um patreon i
mean there's so many different only fans
there's so many different ways to make
money now
and it could have been all youtube like
all that money could all just been
youtube but
you know now it's like there's so many
different
like podcasts and you know so i don't
know
i'm i'm i want to use youtube as a place
where i like can just have fun and not
um do but like you know hopefully our po
hopefully our podcast ends up making
some money
he's shouting yeah he's shouting to
bryce because we have the same producers
actually casper's podcast
shoots right next to us we won't show
you the set though because
i mean it's offensive to get the
permission
it's pretty pretty rugged over there but
like
uh
me too i love them because it's like not
that it's easy to do it's just like
you can either listen or watch and i
like that you get to talk for a long
time
yes because with youtube especially in
the old days it was very like
keep it under five minutes three minutes
and every second has to be funny
yeah yeah which we never accomplished
yeah tick-tock yeah yeah i don't see
there was a
cut-off period where i didn't i stopped
downloading new apps yeah like snapchat
i didn't do snapchat and anything that
came after me neither
yeah i got into tick tock for a little
bit only but i was very has i was like i
hate this i don't like new things but i
was like oh no
adults do that they're like we won't do
new things i'm like i don't want to be
that
i'm settling into that so i i started
watching tick tock with the pandemic
when that happened because i was like i
got extra time now
and i actually like thought it was funny
i kind of got the joke of it like
like what people do on it it's not like
vine yeah it's like
there's just inside jokes basically and
inside trends and
it's it's kind of fun um but it's all
right
yeah well now it's getting banned i
think but yeah oh they gotta sell it
too late double the next one the next
one
yeah they're i'm not against any of
those things it's just it became real
hard to like
manage all those yes i just started like
instagramming like
regularly mm-hmm you know where like i'm
using the stories yeah
know i could barely store it yeah they
go away after 24 hours
yeah they have reels now that's the new
tick tock for instagram
um yeah a lot a lot i know yeah
there was a lot and uh so yeah there's
there's a lot of things we can do now to
kind of express whatever it is when you
started instagram though because
i mean when i first got on it was like
2011 and there weren't that many people
on like that i knew actually mine was
private at first because i didn't know
it was going to be a social media app i
thought it was just
a thing with friends um but you were you
post a lot of artsy stuff on there you
were posting sunsets
more than just like very handsome
uh yeah well i was like yeah that's a
soft side yeah that's what happens
i got a dog yeah yeah i was like living
by the beach and i was like oh god like
i could be the filter on this that was
still when you were doing like satire or
dark humor comedy so like it was like
wow look at this guy yeah
yeah yeah uh you know what's funny there
was before instagram i was on a site
called daily booth
oh yeah yeah oh you're dating yourself
now daily booth and i was hot on daily
yeah but like you know the problem was
it was like they didn't have an app
it was just a web it was a website yeah
it's an old school like a url
yeah it's a www one and uh
they they were like dude you guys you
gotta come up with this uh
app soon because like this other side
instagram is like
they're kind of doing what you're doing
and they're not big yet but they will be
and then they just kind of drop the ball
yeah and all those followers i had on
daily booth just like got deleted and
then i was like okay i guess i'll move
over to instagram and um
yeah that and that and i did just post
like
kind of fun little yeah vignettes
and like that that was the thing is
everyone was an artist at the beginning
of instagram
yeah it was fun it was fun to like sit
there
and go through the photos that you took
all day and then like spend
30 minutes on one photo and tweaking it
yeah or
when you used to do the collages because
that was big back then too yeah true i
remember making a conscious decision
and thinking should i keep the original
four photos or should i just keep this
one photo and save the memory because my
phone doesn't have a lot of space
and then i'm like you know what [ __ ] i'm
saving the originals because i'm
probably going to regret not saving
those
but i never looked back on them either
but it's just so funny i can't delete
any of my
my photos like i just need the memories
i need to like hold on to them i don't
know why
i always think i'm going to sit through
them when i'm an old lady and then just
be like
we don't have physical photo albums
anymore so it does make sense
um but he is a gimmassic on instagram
yes backwards because some like like
chubby little kid had my really had
some g yeah yeah and i was like hey can
i get this handle and he was like no
i'll sell it to you
and he was just a chubby cheek like 12
year old
yeah uh no i said 50 bucks no i wouldn't
know i would have never paid
i was originally at not nikki on
instagram and
totally sketched michael gallagher was
the one that's like you need to have
your branding consistent
yeah and i was like wow fine yeah and
michael was like 17 at the time like
knew more than all of us he really made
his first movie but by the time he was
like 20
well he was on the ground floor of like
the generation that
understands all the apps and they're
born into it like we're i feel like
we're on the edge
like we still had the phones that
connected to the wall and stuff
and like that you had to dial the extra
long cord yeah the curly kick yeah go
around yeah
and then we're like when cell phones
happen we're like whoa it's crazy
it's like zach morris yeah yeah yeah
yeah
yeah and so yeah this new generation
they're born with like ipads in their
hands and it's
it's crazy how like i've been watching
these youtube videos
of kids that develop apps and they're
making like six figure incomes
they're literally in 10 years old like
i'm not joking about the age
not like how we're exaggerating mine
like they're actually 10 years old wow
well they're making coding more yeah
more into the curriculum of this
like school see that that i get yeah we
learned cursive
perfect i do have great handwriting that
nobody will ever
oh and since it's your romance side you
can write birthday cards and like
yeah handwritten cards i made stephen
card
ladies i love letters there we go it's
happening guys
jess you got some competition after this
episode comes out competition
yeah like who is my competition the
viewers
the ladies out there well yeah my dm's
are going to be flooded
they're
hope you guys got a lot of mops to clean
up all the moisture
um but yeah some mops to clean up the
puddles that they're cleaning up your
whops
yes
if they want to find you what's what's
your just search kasam on instagram and
twitter
and yeah and then on and then pajama
pants oh yeah pajama pants is podcasts i
do with
um my buddies rob eiler and jamie lynn
zigler
who are sopranos they were on the
sopranos and i tried doing my best to
not talk about the sopranos oh
it's very tough so all they do is like
oh we're legends we're like
yeah i'm like on youtube um yeah so
pajama pants podcast pajama pants
podcast check it out
um and you know we'll probably all be
guests on there so
yeah we're gonna need more chairs yeah
yeah yeah why don't we just shoot your
episode
just do it right now we can just shoot
shoot it right now
that's so funny um and then um subscribe
and rate us on itunes we love it we love
you guys
see you next time bye bye